I thought I did a really good job on the
beat like every single time there's the
metronome and I whenever the beat can he
beat huh
white why'd you say it to me like that
he said to me like I'm an idiot
what you think I'm some kind of idiot
micro yeah you doing reject nation we're
gonna watch a video today the question
but yeah Austin Harris which is that
surgery break ghazal choices and I'm
Mike Rowe this is from the channel rage
tributes whoo this guy must have anger
problems
oh and must like you know attributing
stuff to people who are mad John you're
a do this so ready Austin Harris just
had surgery this is your patron video
request buddy I hope you recover well
soon in the meantime let's watch some
Frank Castle play by John Eber and all
why were my Batman shirt today
[Music]
damn straight does
[Music]
do this I want to do reata's was easy
for me
Punisher where I replace all the guns of
guitars killing
this I want to see more Frank Castle
[Music]
physical has a great see your way to job
were told he has best best misty eye
maybe he doesn't pull tear a lot but
he's got good misty eyes stay damn
he's got good a tough guy crime
[Music]
that's part of the plan yeah
I'm standing he does she use that
gambling gun in the [ __ ] show don't
worry you guys best gunfight a TV shows
the history crusher
[Applause]
[Music]
stepping right in and
[Music]
it's time
[Music]
we have to choose
[Music]
mmm good job Tommy well done it's good
job dummy good job good be there Eddie
they're not following video you know
those things are a lot harder to edit
then people realize actually I've done
two of those kinds of edits one for
fight scenes another one for the DC
movies really is like a lot of mapping
out magic for a TV show that that's a
lot harder because you got to think of
all the right moments from so many hours
of television tailored to your music you
gotta choose moments that appropriately
build and break it's kind of like using
a shot list and yeah assembling it to
the beat watching this is reminding me
that Frank Castle has the best misty
eyes
yeah see I like Shia LaBeouf does good
misty eye to Jon Bernthal this is the
best man cry he also does it good just
like looking like [ __ ] and still going I
don't like Matt Damon at the end of the
Bourne Supremacy or just looks like he's
gonna fall over but that for like a
whole season yeah like looking terrible
but I'm still gonna get the job to the
most cringy realistic part is the
stabbing okay cut say like the three
different stabbing moments and then one
of the guys jugular or that one I
character was and Punisher season
nothing well you're not you'd like
something these shows also have done is
is show more of that because I'm again
being used to movies you always hear
about like we originally had like twenty
two strikes or whatever we had to cut it
down to three so like yeah you you watch
those fights you're like oh yeah
stabbings are Savage so just like worst
I was in gunshot wounds in a way like
they're differently savage but yeah like
they're they're personal I guess because
you can just pound and I thought what
was really cool about this I mean this
song is featured in The Punisher I
thought the way he put this together
because sometimes you watch these
compilations and they're like they're
cool this one actually does represent
the soul and the spirit of Frank Castle
pretty well that's what a good yeah cuz
he he knew the right moments to put
together called rage tributes and you do
get that because it's more than just him
pissed like you you feel the turmoil of
Frank Castle in a lot of these clips in
the torture I think Jon Bernthal his
performance has something to do with
helping that Frank Grillo did to like
co-star and something things will
devolve into grunts and shoot it maybe
maybe he can he could play bring him
back because you could do that he could
first the Punisher I'd be cool
crossbones versus Punisher to bony dude
yeah Punisher wins in a minute and
everybody yeah yeah but you know it's
what we cooled why this would be cool to
watch cuz you know Frank castles better
than everybody that would be pretty cool
actually
if Marvel did that or they'd take like
one of the smaller characters from one
of the movies and put them in the TV
shows how be cool cuz everyone's like oh
man crossbones is such a cool character
the comics he doesn't get used he just
gets killed off so early in civil war
spoiler post
spoiler alert warning that would be need
to bring him in there actually good idea
John good idea let's talk to Kevin see
if we can get a ulysses klaw and when
these shows yeah any circus hey Austin
buddy recovery stuff man after surgery
post surgery recovery stuff sure that I
want you to know you're a trooper I'm
glad you made it out alive dude I find
it fascinating that you chose this video
to be is so it makes me wonder do you
have rage problems I can imagine someone
who's been going through what you've
been going through that you would have
some serious issues of rage if that's
the case I'm will and help you out not
in terms of therapeutic treatment or
bettering your mental health or talking
about your past I'm willing to
contribute to your rage any type of
weapon that can cause harm to other
people I'm your dude okay I got a whole
arsenal supply in my closet right in
that bedroom dude so if you want to get
out some rage just hit me up man I could
help you out dude I could help you out
therapy doesn't do any good just take it
out on other people I think that's what
we really learned from the story of
Frank Castle yeah revenge is a dish that
best serves your mental health
Sang's renewing and ending on proverb at
the beginning of Kill Bill Vol 1
eat some applesauce and enjoy a little
time off your feet you know what also
helps some medicinal God medicine hey
man it can be nice after surgery he's
like people just take care of you for
you know however long you have to be out
of commission yeah it's true it's like
your only time in your adult life you
get to feel kinda like a kid again and
also you're gonna see it the old
Dogville signs you're gonna help out
with that too no I'm just I I could help
you out with that after you get your
rage out oxytocin because you can't
build a house on the sand it'll sink you
got to get the rage out first of course
I'm sorry I I forgot how rage works
trust me they're infected with what
leash all right guys you can subscribe
you real rejects click that notification
bar we'll catch you on the youtubes and
the pet rounds
you